Hello, everybody.
Hello, it's me, Dokio.
I am a little low energy today.
It has been a lot of stuff going on the last couple of days.
I don't know if I want to put the hat on, guys.
Hat or no hat on, guys.
I don't know.
I think if I could turn off the bed, if I could, like, just snip the bird feathers, me, the teeny hat on, the hat stays on.
Anyway, I was gonna say, oh, yes, I am a little bit low energy.
Obviously, a lot of stuff has been going on.
Um, let me, actually, let me turn off the game music, because it's a little annoying while I just give you guys a little life update.
Um, anyway, um, B, put on the cat ears and B, cat Mario.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
You always want Dough Kitty.
Every time.
I still have, I'm still here.
Doughkey Bird is still the main character of this channel.
It can't always be Dough Kitty.
Men only want one thing.
Um, this channel is, uh, Doughkey Bird, not Dough Kitty.
Uh, not Doughkey Cat.
It's, uh, Doughkey Bird.
Anyway, um, life update.
So, if you guys didn't know, um, Doughkey Amber Doge Dad, um, I recently picked him up, uh, yesterday at the vet hospital.
Um, he is doing okay.
Um, they gave me, okay, so, after I, like, you know, I was at the hospital, and then, you know, we had to do, like, a, you know, discharge information stuff about, like, um, what to prepare for.
So, he's at the dog sitter, and the dog sitter's the one that's gonna be, like, taking care of him for the first two weeks.
Um, they're unsure they can take care of him after the first, after the two weeks are over, because, oh my god, looking at, it's so awkward to see myself talk with a mustache.
I'm sorry.
The mustache is so distracting.
I'm not gonna, I mean, I'm not looking at myself.
No, no.
The mustache is actually, I'm, like, trying to give, like, a serious life update right now, and, like, I just see the mustache, and I'm, like, okay, it's so hard to be serious, right?
Um, anyway, um, as I was saying, um, the mustache stays on!
Anyway, um, so, um, the, you know, okay, so for those who don't know, uh, dad had to, the reason why dad was at the hospital was because he, he must have jumped and landed wrong, um, and he is a wiener dog, so he is a dachshund, and for those who don't know about dachshunds,
uh, they are, they are, their bodies are too long for jumping, but they don't know that, um, they're, they're too stubborn and stupid to realize, genetically, they're not supposed to jump, but they, but somehow, despite being bred to not jump, they are also,
genetically, it is encoded in their personalities to jump.
So, like, it conflicts a lot.
Like, they don't know that!
They don't know they're not allowed to jump, but they love jumping!
He's like, I will jump, despite what genetics or nature told me to.
Um, bees are genetically supposed to be not able to fly, but they do fly!
So, uh, um, so, anyway, um, anyway, so, basically, that was what the whole thing was about.
Um, and I did tell you guys, oh my god, every time I look in the corner of my eye, I just see myself with a mustache, and it is so distracting.
It is!
Our destiny is not written in our genes!
He, unfortunately, he was not the first wiener dog to, to, um, overcome his genetic coding.
That is so unfortunate that he was not the one to overcome it.
Anyway, so, if you guys didn't know that, uh, this is, like, the wiener dog owner's worst fear, which was to basically have a wiener dog that jumped and fucked up his back, because that's what he did.
Uh, he was, he was just trying to evolve, let him live, it's like, well, now, I have to pay $10,000!
So, he is not evolving no more!
Um, so, yes, anyway, uh, yes, this, I had to pay the very expensive surgery.
Uh, yes, now you realize why it's not cool for wiener dogs to jump!
I mean, sorry, I should have, like, coaxed that in more.
Um, freedom with a cost!
Uh, so, for those who don't know, these types of surgeries are incredibly expensive.
Um, but I want him to be able to walk because of what he did.
So, you know, he tried to fucking, he tried to, like, put himself in the handicap position.
He tried to make himself handicapped by jumping, And I was like, no, you are not allowed to not walk.
So, I had to pay the very expensive surgery to make sure he's still able to walk.
And he is not allowed to.
Okay, anyway.
Alright, so that was a short TLDR.
Sorry, I was going to give a longer story.
And, like, you know, coaxed into everything.
But, you guys are like, he wants to be free.
Well, I'm sorry, but I had to pay a lot of money to make sure you have your legs.
Anyway, okay.
Alright, let me retell this story.
Wonder5, thank you for the...
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Anyway.
Anyway, guys.
Back to the actual story.
So, we took him to the vet.
At first, you know, the vet first, we didn't take him to the specialist.
Because there is also a specialist hospital regarding, like, you know, regarding, like, neurological problems.
Which is what dad has.
Because, you know, it's like the infamous...
I forgot what it's called.
It's like the IVV, was it?
It's like the disc.
The disc in the spine.
And, like, it's, like, basically the disc on the spine.
Like, skewered in a way where, like...
Usually...
It's like two things.
It's either surgery or, like, rehabilitation.
Rehabilitation or, like, it's either surgery or rehabilitation slash physical therapy.
And then hope it gets better.
So, we had two options.
We either, like, just see it and let it recover on its own.
Or we get surgery.
So, the recovery...
We tried to do the recovery on its own.
But, obviously, it got worse.
So, that's why we took him to the neurological, like, specialist hospital.
Because, like, he started getting, like, wobbly and stuff like that.
Like, we could notice that he started wobbling.
And, like, he felt like when he was walking, it felt like he didn't really know how to walk a little.
So, it obviously felt like it was getting worse.
And then we're like, okay, we should take him to the specialist just to see what's going on.
And the specialist was like, yes, you could try to, like, continue.
Like, he still has, like, reaction to his legs.
Like, you know, he still was able to react to it and still has feeling in his legs.
But, like, we don't know if it will get better or worse.
So, if you do rehabilitation and physical therapy without the surgery, it was, like, a 60 to 80% chance of whether or not he'll recover from it.
And then, uh, so obviously, but we do surgery, it was, like, 90 to 98%.
So, I was like, I'm going with surgery.
Like, they're like, okay, obviously, there's costs and stuff involved.
Um, I was most afraid it was gonna be cancer.
Because then, the doctor was like, or it could be cancer.
And then, I was like, oh, what?
So, the vet was like, or it could be cancer.
So, let's hope it's just related to the disc.
So, I was like, oh, what?
You mean it?
There's a chance it could be cancer?
So, um, because, like, so we're gonna have to do an x-ray first.
Um, let's do an x-ray first to see if there's, like, any, like, lumps or anything.
And then, if there isn't, we'll go right into the CT scan.
Um, so, so I was like, oh, my God, I hope it's just the back.
I hope, I hope he broke his back and it's not cancer.
Like, um, uh, the doula, yeah, and, so, because I didn't think of that.
I was like, it can be cancer?
Like, I was like, um, um, but, like, it wasn't cancer.
It was just a typical wiener dog jumped too hard, jumped too much, um, and broke his back.
Um, not broke it, but, like, he slipped a disc.
So, so, basically, what they did was, you know, I was like, do the operation.
Like, they're like, it is pretty expensive.
And I was like, I don't care, just do the surgery.
Because it was, like, a 90 to 98% chance of a recovery.
And obviously, like, I like my, I like my odds with the 90% to 98%.
That sounds like really good odds there.
And he was still able to walk.
It's not like he was, like, um, paraplegic coming in.
Like, it's not like he lost the use of his legs coming in.
So, like, he went in, still able to walk.
So, like, there is a higher chance of recovery because of it.
It's not like he did the surgery and then, like, bam, it's worse.
So, like, in my, I hope I was glad it wasn't that.
Um, but obviously, like, um, the first day.
Okay, and then, uh, they were telling me he'd have to stay in the hospital an extra day.
Because, like, they want to do, like, a rehabilitation therapy session with him.
So, like, they had to do, like, physical therapy for him.
And, like, making sure, um, uh, I don't, okay?
Hey, you guys wanted me to put the mustache on.
Like, like,
I couldn't take it off to tell the story.
I couldn't.
You guys wanted it on.
Anyway, as I was saying, he went in, um, when we, uh, he, they said that he was wobbly, a little worse after the surgery.
But, obviously, like, it wasn't expected.
Because he literally just, they literally cut his back.
They cut his back open and trimmed off, like, this.
Because I didn't realize what type of operation it was.
Like, I don't know what is actually involved.
I got, like, really nervous.
Because they're like, oh, yeah, we took bits of his, like, disc out and everything.
And then I didn't, I didn't realize what was actually happening.
And I was just like, oh, my God, is his spine shorter?
He's like, I thought they were removing stuff.
So I was like, did they, like, shorten him up?
And they're like, no, no, no.
That's not how it works.
It's like, we trimmed the, like, basically, parts of the disc, like, grew out, like, improperly.
And, like, grew and slipped.
And then, so...
So we have to trim it.
And that's why his back was, like, slanted.
Because, yeah, I was like, is that what you see?
Like, now the size of a regular, like, his length is a regular dog instead of, like, like, instead of a wiener dog?
Because I didn't know, like, a wiener reduction surgery?
Because I didn't know what the surgery implies.
But, no, they just, like, trimmed it.
Trimmed the disc.
Because it was, like, out of line.
So, um, so it was, like, you know, so they had to trim it out.
And stuff that, like, the disc that grew improperly and made it out of line from the spine.
Um, so, so that's what it was.
Like, on a wiener's side, I learned that that day.
I learned what the surgery was.
Because they were like, yeah, the surgery was a success.
I was like, um, is he, like, short?
Like, I literally asked, um, did you, do you make him, like, shorter?
Like, did you shorten?
I literally asked if he, they shortened the spine.
I was like, is he less long now?
Like, because I didn't understand.
Because they're like, yeah, we, like, took out some of the discs.
So, in my head, I was like, my god, is my wiener dog not a wiener anymore?
Anyways, but that's not what happened.
They just trimmed it.
And so, basically, he is still... he is wobbly, more wobbly, right now, because it is post-surgery.
So, obviously, that fucking feels weird for him, because it's like, you know, he literally just got his back exposed to the world, and, like, they, like, fucking operated on it.
So, he does... it's, like, he does have, like, less... he has more balance issues, but, um...
But they said it does... it will get better, and, like, it will improve, and we just need to give him, like, physical therapy and rehabilitation, and make sure that, like, he doesn't jump as much anymore, or at all, which is gonna be very hard, because he doesn't understand that.
Like, he... he... he doesn't know that.
He's... he's like, what?
Less jumping?
What is that?
He wants to be tall.
So, anyway...
Um, what else?
Oh, yeah, and then they, like, gave me a vial...
of, like...
of, like, the disc...
of the...
of the pieces of disc.
And I was, like, you know, they're, like, you don't have to keep it.
And I was, like, oh, no, that's okay.
Because I felt like I was in... on the spot, and I was, like, okay.
So, I... I kept it.
It's in my... it's in my bag.
I haven't, like, taken it out or looked at it.
I feel like... I feel like I should throw it away.
But I basically have a vial of liquid and, like, bits of his bone...
like, disc bone...
like, in my bag.
And I was, like, telling my manager about it.
And then...
Oh, my God.
Dad's fine.
Okay.
And then I was telling my manager, I was, like, you know, I could sell...
Okay, it was as a joke.
This was as a joke.
I was, like, I could sell this.
And then...
And then I was, like, oh, wait.
No, I could sign my autograph on the vial.
And...
And then auction it up.
And then my manager was, like, oh, you know what else you can do?
You can sell...
Because there's more than one piece, and there's, like, bits and pieces.
You can buy additional vials.
Divide the pieces out.
So you can maximize your profits.
That's a joke, guys.
It's a joke.
I will not sell pieces of my dog's spine.
To you, guys.
It's a collector's item.
I will get your own piece of dad so you can clone him.
Oh, you can use it to clone your own dad!
Oh, my God.
You guys are so smart.
Guys, we...
You guys can clone your own dad with those pieces.
Oh, my God.
Anyway.
I'm not gonna show a picture of it.
Because I think that might be a little too gross.
And I don't know if YouTube would like that I showed a vial of pieces of my dog's insides on YouTube.
So I won't show it.
But yes, he...
I will show you a video of...
Okay, by the way.
They obviously had to shave a...
Shave a spot.
Clone the dog with the most genetic issues you've ever heard of.
Many, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Robin's mustache.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I bet they go for more than a piece of paper, dude.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway.
But, so for the surgery, obviously, they had to shave the back to, like, you know, operate on.
Um, so, like, I didn't... Okay, so, I was really worried because they asked me to visit...
They said I could visit him at any time before I picked him up for discharge.
But, like, I got really scared because, like, I didn't visit him, like, the two days.
Uh, because I got really scared that he was gonna get too excited and, like, was gonna, like...
Like, I didn't want him to move, so I didn't visit him because I was really scared.
And then the dog sitter also didn't visit because, like, they were also really scared that he was gonna get too excited.
And, like, obviously, like, open his wounds and stuff.
So, but then when I saw him during the discharge, um...
Because it was obviously, like, you know, I didn't want him to, like, break his back again.
Like, that was what I was most scared of.
And when we were... when we picked him up for the discharge, he was just, like, shaking a lot.
And I was so worried.
I was like, is that normal?
And then the vet was like, yeah, he's just really, really excited.
So that's why he's just shaking with excitement.
So I was just like, oh, my God.
And then I saw, like, his naked back.
And I was like, oh, my... And, like, there's, you know, obviously there's a line on where the spine is.
And I was like, oh, my God.
You're even more involved.
It's just like... I mean, I can show a video.
I do have a video that the dog sitter sent me of the...
Okay, let's see.
I do have a video that the dog sitter sent me of him using the bathroom.
If you guys want... But he is wobbly.
Like, it was basically today's update.
If you guys want to see it, you want to see Dad.
But he is... He is a little wobbly.
He is wobbly.
You can tell he is wobbly.
But he is recovering.
But yeah, let me grab it real quick.
But he is recovering, guys.
He might be wobbly, but he is getting better.
All right, let me find it real quick.
Where is it?
Oh, right now?
Okay, give me a second.
I need to download it.
I sent it to myself.
I forgot to... I forgot to download the video.
All right, nice.
All right.
It's too... I might be a bit too loud, though.
Uh...
Whoops.
Here's the video.
All right.
There he is.
You can tell that...
That's...
That's not a band-aid, by the way.
That's not...
That's not a...
That's not a band-aid.
That's literally...
It's like a patch of...
A patch of fur that's gone.
Like...
It's just...
That's the skin, guys.
I know when I saw the video, I was like...
I was like, oh my god.
That's...
That's the bald spot where they had to...
You know, shave off and then...
Cut that part of the spine open...
The skin open.
But you can tell that he is...
He is a little wobbly.
But, like...
You can tell that he is, like...
A little uncoordinated.
But...
But he's...
He's doing a lot better.
He...
We're not bullying him!
We're not...
He...
It's just like...
He's, like, a little drunk.
But, like...
It's just that...
Obviously, he just got operated on...
Like, a few days ago.
But, um...
He is...
He is recovering.
And, um...
He's on a lot of meds, too.
There's also the fact that...
The textures didn't load properly.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to mention...
He is incredibly drugged up right now.
He's on...
He is on...
Four different medications.
Um...
And...
So, he has, like...
Like...
Several, like...
Painkillers.
Muscle relaxant.
Um...
Two other types of, like...
He's on...
Yeah.
So, there's also...
There's also that.
He's on...
Four different...
Fucking medication.
To deal with everything.
Um...
And he has to take them, like...
Three times a day.
So, you guys can see why...
The dog sitter is taking care of him right now.
Instead of me.
Because...
I have...
Unfortunately, have...
A very busy work schedule.
Especially for this month.
And next month.
So...
Or for, like...
Yeah.
For April and May.
I unfortunately have, like...
A really busy work schedule.
So...
I can't supervise him...
24-7.
Um...
Because of it.
Because...
Like, you know...
With what he's going through...
He needs 24-7 care.
And I'm very lucky that...
The dog sitter and, like...
Because, like, their entire family is taking care of...
Uh...
Dad right now.
And...
And obviously, they're supervising him.
Um...
They're supervising him.
Making sure that he's okay.
He's in this little crate thing.
Um...
Where he just sits there the whole day.
But yes...
The care is expensive.
But it's worth it.
Uh...
You might notice that...
Um...
We are going to be taking at least one sponsor per week.
The next couple of weeks.
Because, like I said...
Like I said...
It was technically more than $10,000.
Um...
Because the surgery alone was $10,000.
So...
That...
That didn't include, like...
The scans...
And the...
And the hospital visit...
Staying at the hospital.
So...
It was...
But I'm really thankful...
For your support, guys.
Um...
To help me be able to afford...
The surgery.
And everything.
So...
If it wasn't for you guys...
For supporting me...
And supporting...
Doki Amber Doge.
Um...
We can...
We are able to afford the surgery.
And, you know...
I am taking these extra sponsors...
To help pad out...
You know...
My finances.
Or the fact that...
Um...
I have to pay for the dog sitter...
And, like...
Obviously...
To make up for the funds...
That I used...
For his care...
Because he decided...
Genetically...
That he wasn't gonna follow...
His genetic destiny...
Even though, like...
He should've.
I remember, like...
The hospital vet...
Was like...
The doctor was like...
Okay, so...
You gotta make sure he doesn't do this...
And that...
For his recovery...
And then...
The dog sitter...
Because, like...
The dog sitter was with me...
He was with me during...
Throughout it...
And he was like...
Did you tell...
Did you tell Doki that?
Like...
Did you tell Dad that?
Um...
Because, obviously...
I named him after myself...
Um...
But he was like...
Did you tell...
Did you tell the dog that?
And then...
Because...
And he was like...
He's very stubborn...
Um...
But yeah...
CyberDragal...
Thank you for that...
AlkaSupa...
Thank you...
Thank you for that...
Thank you again.
Solid snake.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Anything.
For the goodness boy and dad.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh, OK.
Now I'm just... I wish I was...
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
But yeah, that's the current life update regarding his care.
I'm going to be... I do get regular updates every day on how he's doing as well as videos and photos.
I'm planning on like visiting him too, whenever I'm free from work or like behind the scenes stuff.
But yeah, he's doing great.
Thank you for everybody that sent him well wishes and that were wondering if he's okay and was like wondering about like, you know, his updates on like after his surgery and everything.
I really appreciate everybody for caring so much about him as much as I care about him as well.
So thank you guys.
Anyway, um, another life update.
Another life update.
Um, next week on Sunday, I will be checking out the early... I was invited to check out the early access for the new Apex character and Apex season.
So they invite... Respawn has invited me to check out the early access next week.
It is going to be on Sunday because that's when it starts.
Because usually I don't, you know, usually, um, I don't post the schedule out, um, until then.
I'm doing my one too.
I'll do it on YouTube and then, um, because it is two days and apparently there are special drops for it.
I might do, maybe I'll do the next one on, I'll do another stream on, on Monday as a bonus on Twitch because there are special drops for this event.
Um, but I will tweet about it later as well.
So I'll be back on, it's been a while.
I will say it has been a while.
Since I've, um, played Apex.
I remember during the, during my convention at St. Louis, um, some guy at the panel asked me what I feel about Sierra.
And like, I need stories I want to talk about Sierra.
And then I was like, oh buddy, I don't know if you know this, but we're on the Marvel Rivals ground.
I was like, let me check when was the last time I, I, I played Apex and I looked at my, you know, play history and the last time I've opened the game, I don't know about playing the game, but the last time I opened the game was March 10th.
So like...
So I was like, oh buddy, that's, uh, you're a little too late for him to ask me that.
To ask me about Sierra, cause I don't know what the fuck is going on.
But yes, I'm not sponsored to do so.
Um, they just sent me an invite to check out the new season.
And, you know, obviously I would, um, I love to have that opportunity, um, to do so.
So like, of course I said yes, because like, you know, it's a special invite and I wanted, I, it's been a while since I looked into Apex in a long time.
And I'm, I'm hyped to see like what, what they're gonna, what changes there are, what's the new characters gonna be like and everything.
Cause you know, it's nice to check out new characters and stuff and see like what they do.
So that's gonna be on Sunday.
I don't know what the time is, cause like, I didn't fully read my briefing.
Jeff, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Is it tax deductible if I mark this super chat as to add some medical care?
But seriously, hope he gets better, thank you, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You know, like, um, I recently got, I'm doing a, okay, so you know how I'm doing the, what was it, girls?
Wait, what was, I, I, I don't remember the full name.
The girls battlefront, was that?
Oh my gosh.
It's okay, today's not the sponsored day, so I can butcher it a little bit, cause I'm not, technically I'm not sponsored yet.
Girls front line, I was almost right.
Girls front line too.
And then, um, and then, uh, oh wait, no, it wasn't for that.
Oh, nevermind.
I did read the briefing for it.
Um, but it wasn't the one that was, like, super long.
So, I'm, I'm doing a sponsor, a different sponsor in two weeks.
Um, this one I am looking forward to, because, um, it's always, it's a sponsor I never expected to get.
Um, but I was super excited.
Um, because it was, it's a game that I used to play a lot.
That, just a little hint of what that sponsor could be.
Um, um, so, they sent me a briefing.
And then, um, I was like, I just told my manager.
I was like, oh yeah, no, take the sponsor.
Like, that's, that, take it.
Like, I don't, this also helps with paying off the, the surgery.
And then, and then, um, my manager was like, did you read the briefing?
And I was like, no.
And then, my manager was like, it's 20 pages.
They're like, you're gonna take it, but he didn't.
I was like, oh.
I was like, I was like, 20 pages.
Oh, shit.
Um, I was like, okay.
I can, I'll, I'll read it.
I swear, I'll read it.
Okay.
I swear.
I'll read the contract.
I'll read the briefing.
Yeah, I was not expecting 20 pages of info.
I just, I just thought, that's a cool sponsor.
Take it.
Anyway.
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
You listen to the music while, when I'm gone.
I'm back for real now.
All right.
Hello, everybody.
Oh.
Let me make sure that everything is okay.
I'm gonna put that up here.
All right, guys.
All right.
So, that is the entire life update so far.
So, yeah.
There's a lot of stuff coming up.
A lot of sponsors.
There's, there is another, there is a Tokyo Alley convention, which is in Australia, for those who are, those who are from Australian goons.
You guys can see me at Australia for Tokyo Alley.
And then there's FanimeCon, which was, is also in May, which is a huge convention there.
And I believe the meet and greets are, I think the meet and greets are free for it.
I think you just have to line up, I believe.
I'm not sure.
I'm not 100% sure.
But, like, you know, I could be lying.
I could be lying.
I should read this more properly.
May or may not be free.
Um, but, I am accepting, accepting gifts for both Tokyo Alley and FanimeCon.
Um, so yeah.
Just, uh, free with exceptions.
Um.
Maybe I should read it better.
Read my stuff better.
Um, it was a pleasure for you to hear you again at Anime in St. Louis.
I've been working on my ROAR.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got you in the front.
I heard you, like, lined up for 2.5 hours or something for at Anime St. Louis to be, like, a really good seat.
But then you're like, wait, I could have just, like, sat in the front.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
That's a, that's a feels bad.
Ha ha ha.
But I'm glad you still enjoyed it.
I'm, I'm glad you had a great time.
Um, at Anime St. Louis.
Um.
I wish I did sing more for this.
I didn't know.
It was supposed to be karaoke.
Mostly just karaoke.
But, um.
Um, obviously, you know, like, the timing was very unfortunate with everything that was going on, you know, with my dog and everything.
So I asked the convention people if it was okay if I make it, like, half a Q&A panel and half karaoke.
And they said it was fine.
Like, you know, during the circumstances.
And, like, I was like, sorry, guys.
Like, I'm still gonna sing.
It's just that my voice is, like, not the best at the moment at that time.
Um, you know, I was all over the place that day.
Like, the last couple of days for it.
So I'm glad a lot of people still enjoyed, uh, still enjoyed Anime St. Louis.
Um, and had a great time.
That's their very first VTuber guest.
Anyway, let's play the game!
I forgot where I was at this part.
Um, where, where did I progress as Mario?
Mario!
Alright.
I guess I have to go to the world too.
Did I talk to everybody?
Did I talk to everyone here?
I think so.
I'll just go forward.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, I remembered!
I remembered!
Okay.
So, there's a lot of bullets here that wanna kill me.
I remember now.
And then I, yeah, and I killed this guy.
And did I kill him?
I don't remember if I killed him.
Yeah.
Oh, wait!
Do I have Toadie?
No, I don't!
Toadie!
Alright.
Let's see.
Um, okay, I'll do Spark first.
I don't know if Spark's gonna kill him.
Okay, nevermind.
I forgot he's flying.
Hahaha!
I forgot!
Electricity!
Bad!
Hahaha!
Oh, look!
It's been a while!
I don't remember my type advantages, okay?
You're on the... Oh, nice.
Nice.
Rewind time.
I killed your sister.
Okay.
And it's... Okay, fighting is also bad.
I remembered.
Birds can't fight or use electricity.
Alright.
Okay, I still killed him.
Okay.
Hahaha!
Okay, look.
I might be a little too strong.
I might be a little...
Asking once again to be Goonified for it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Wait, I don't need Leech Seed.
That's not an attack move.
Yeah, no.
Wait.
No, I won't stop learning.
Le... No.
Okay, yes.
We do not learn Leech Seed.
And then we do this.
Yay!
Alright.
Don't worry.
We have another...
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's just kill him for XP.
This is your...
This is your job.
You're just here for XP.
All right.
Get out of here.
Nice.
You're right.
I should start...
I should send out...
Wait.
Can I go through here?
Did I go through here yet?
I don't remember.
Were you lost here?
Oh, yeah.
I did went through here.
Yeah, I did go through here.
Guys, it's been a while.
I lose track of things.
Oh, I found a one-up mushroom.
Hello, fight me.
Check out my sick party, Mario.
Yeah?
How sick is it?
What the fuck?
A bully?
Oh, wait.
That's in Mario 64.
I remember him.
All right.
Get here.
Get firefighting.
I already have a...
I already have a red one.
I want you another one.
Oh, shit.
I don't even know my type advantages, but I got it right.
Oh, you got withdraw...
Oh, you're a coward.
Oh, look.
It's Tootie.
Don't worry.
I've killed your brothers and sisters.
I can kill them again.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Wait.
Fighting is good...
Is bad against...
I don't remember.
It's been so many years.
I can't remember the type advantages.
It's been too long.
I don't understand.
Why is fighting bad against birds?
What the fuck is the bird gonna do?
Have you ever punched a bird?
I can if they stop flying away.
It's really hard to punch...
Punch a bird.
I don't believe it.
I need...
I...
Great boy.
If I...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Is this...
It's a ghost mouse.
So...
Wait.
Electricity doesn't work on...
Ghosts?
I can't...
Why doesn't electricity work on ghosts?
Oh my god.
I'm so confused.
Dad, wake up!
Oh, it does.
Why didn't it say it fell?
Wait.
Are you a ground ghost?
Okay.
It's okay.
I have another type.
Yeah.
But fighting didn't work.
Oh, it might be ground ghost.
The fuck?
How is a mouse...
How is a mouse ground?
It floats.
I'm so confused.
The confused rate also hurt me.
Have you tried punching a ghost before?
Yeah.
Punched me.
She didn't phase through it.
Weren't they cool?
I mean...
Darn you, Mario.
Alright.
Maybe I should.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I did not heal.
I came out of the Pokemon Center and I didn't even use the...
I didn't even...
Okay.
That's a little awkward.
I like literally came out of the Pokemon Center and didn't even use it.
Whoops.
Whoopsie.
That's awkward.
Alright.
Let's take...
Go back so we can at least heal...
Oh, baby.
Thank you for that.
Get the ship.
Thank you.
So at least we can heal the dragon and catch a toady.
Just to complete my Pokedex.
Or my...
Tattle Dex.
Alright.
Get in here.
Or my Tattle Dex.
What is it even called?
This isn't...
This isn't called a Pokemon Center, right?
What do they call it?
The CC?
The fuck is a CC?
Command Center?
Alright.
Is it...
No, it's...
I'm pretty sure it...
Yeah, it's a Tattle Dex.
Alright.
Now I have to do this all over.
Wait.
Do I have to do...
Yeah, I do.
God damn it.
I'll do this part all over again.
It's so far away.
Uh...
The calm...
The capsule core.
Whoa!
Tuck Puff!
What are you?
You seem rather tough.
Alright.
Let's put...
Dragon in here.
I don't have...
Yeah, I don't have him because there's no Pokeball on it.
It's a cloud!
Why is it yellow?
I don't like that it's yellow.
It makes me uncomfortable.
Don't worry.
Time to lick the cloud.
Ha ha ha!
That's like the only move I'll ever use.
Lick the cloud, Dragon!
Ha ha ha!
Lick it!
That's right.
You know you like it.
You know.
Ha ha ha!
Keep licking.
You lick the cloud.
He's doing his best.
Good job, Dragon!
Know your place.
Ha ha ha!
Please.
Wait.
It contains my cotton candy.
Nice.
Forbidden cotton candy.
Not so dead, but...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki can revamp the ghost adventure shows with her ghost punching abilities.
Yay!
Alright.
A cloud of...
Thank you, yes!
It suffocates its enemies by forcing itself onto their face.
But enemies will often pass out due to their smell instead.
Damn, Dragon.
You a freak.
You a...
Ha ha ha!
Who wanted it?
Was it fo-r?
Alright.
Fo-goon.
Oh, wait.
I spelled it wrong.
Um.
Fo- Fo- Fo- A-goon.
There.
You can beat...
You can beat a fart cloud.
A-goon.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Lick the cloud.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
That's not what I want to do.
No.
Okay.
We gotta get out of here.
Oh, hey.
Yeah.
Let's just kill him.
We throw...
We...
We do like...
We do a grab move on the cloud.
Nice.
It doesn't matter if it's not effective or not.
He's still dead.
We're gonna punch the cloud.
Okay, I forgot to do this.
Alright, nice.
We need to get Toadie in here.
Whoops!
Where's Toadie?
Goddammit, they're all Tough Puffs!
Yeah, I'm pretty sure Tough Puff...
I mean, Tough Puff is an actual Mario enemy.
I've never seen it before.
Maybe from the newer games?
Alright, goodbye Tough Puff.
Yay!
That's not a fighting move.
Yes, stop learning.
Wait, you want to swallow?
Yes.
Guys, I know, like, we don't have Stockpiled.
But, like, I just...
Wait...
We don't even have Stockpiled.
It's not worthless!
You can swallow!
It's not worthless, guys.
Wait!
Okay!
There's no way!
There's no way this wasn't planned.
Alright.
Aw, man.
Did we swallow or...
No.
Wait, now we just need spit.
There's no way that wasn't intentional.
No.
It's worthless without...
Stock doesn't matter.
I want to have choices.
I want to be able to pick.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine Pokemon, but you're ducking people off the streets like a mailman or McDonald's employee and make them cage fight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, this is pretty much it.
Yeah.
Sydney Cookie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Since Minus Green, she can dress up as Luigi and you can dress up as Mario Dokey.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
The only move I need is...
I don't need a bubble.
The only move I need is lick.
Oh my... Dragoon.
You guys are... Oh shit, I got shot at too.
Damn.
You guys are freaky, Dragoon.
Swallow, spit, lick, and bite?
That's one freaky, Dragoon right there.
No, it's not very...
They're like the most common shiny.
What have we learned?
Okay, I think that...
Honestly, I think this is my favorite...
My favorite title Pokemon.
Or Mario-mon.
Swallow, lick, spit, up, bite...
That's you!
That's you, guys!
Look!
Point at you!
That's you!
You guys...
I didn't...
You guys wanted to learn these moves, chat.
You wanted to learn them.
Alright.
Oh my god, and she's female.
It's just perfect.
It's perfect.
Why would I deny you of your...
Why would I deny you guys...
Of your purpose in life?
Can't follow the rules if you don't play the game.
Wait, but you're fighting me.
You're playing the game.
Yeah, would face like that ever lie to you?
Exactly.
Wait.
He's sending his own, like, people to fight me.
Wait, that's pretty fucked if you think about it.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna do a vital throw.
You guys getting a shell?
What the fuck is your shell gonna do about this?
I'm still gonna throw you into the ocean.
We're up in the sky.
I can literally throw you out...
Throw you down and hit you...
Hit the ground.
Delta!
Anyway, can I get a happy birthday?
I am not reading your first sentence.
Thank you for the super chat, Delta.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Delta.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Woo!
All right.
Let's get rid of...
What's the weakest?
Okay, clamp's the weakest.
So get rid of clamp.
Eevee, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why would Doki give this money to a baby?
He's not a baby.
He's level 17.
He's at least a teenager.
All right.
I'm gonna throw you off the cliff.
We're so high up here.
You'll never live.
Oh my god, this takes so long.
Get out of here.
We're up in the sky.
I'm gonna kick you out of the sky.
Doki, that's still not good.
But he's not a baby, though.
All right.
Sport ball.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Help me, Doki.
The maple leaves are collapsing again.
Again.
Why do the hockey gods hate Toronto?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As long as there's no revolts after, then it should be good, right?
That's the only thing I know about hockey.
The riots.
People go crazy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Wait, what do you want to learn?
Bite?
Oh, you want to be a freak, too.
All right.
Bite with...
Functions differently for ghosts.
Wait, are you a ghost?
Okay, bite...
Uh...
Bite.
Okay.
We don't need bite.
That's not an attack move.
Only attacks here.
Nice.
We got $220.
Give me your fucking money.
What happened?
What does this do?
Oh, it's for that.
Okay, we gotta go all the way across, then.
Oh.
Hello?
Hey, hey.
It's quite odd out here, isn't it, Marigo?
One can say it's spiky.
All right.
We gotta kill our spotting now.
All right, Dad.
I only know one move and one move only.
All right.
I know two moves.
Ha ha ha ha.
All right.
That move sucked.
Good for you that I know two moves.
Okay.
And two moves only.
That's right.
Fun shop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Toki.
It's my birthday last Saturday.
I'm glad you and Dad are doing okay.
Are you sure we can't even have even a little...
little Dad's spinal fluid as a treat?
It's the secret of Longgood's creation.
If you get a piece of the spinal fluid, you grow one inch taller.
Ye olde mede...
Medieval...
Uh...
Ye olde medieval medicine.
Just need a little bit.
Just a little drop.
Gotta make soup out of it, too.
But happy belated birthday.
I wish I...
I don't remember if I ever...
Samuel...
Wait, what is he doing here?
Mario!
Wait, that's an admin.
What are these grunts...
Those grunts doing?
Whatever.
I'll stop you myself.
Oh my god, he's a leader.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Fudgetup.
Oh my god, he's all armored up.
Trip, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I should be able to capture him myself.
If, like, I accidentally...
Like, okay, the moment he knocks off...
The moment his hat is off, he's, like, free reign.
To be captured.
What if, like, I just take off his hat...
And just throw a ball at him?
You don't know that.
Nobody will know he was actually a player.
I have a trip, thank you.
What the fuck is that?
That's a shape.
What are you?
Is there a square?
Is there a square hole for you?
That's just a shape.
Oh, no, he made me paralyzed.
Can't do that.
I paid 10K.
That's fucked up.
All right.
Wait.
Stop.
No, I want to learn storms.
Uh, what is this?
Storm throw?
Uh, 60.
Wait, it's weaker.
Okay.
Actually...
Oh, it always results in a critical hit.
Wait, that's good.
I'll get rid of flame charge then.
Is that why your neck...
Yes, every time...
When I see it...
Little dude, I know the reason why he had to get surgery was I drank all his fluids out.
Like, suck a straw...
Through his body.
And then, like, I would...
And then, like, we had to refill his fluids.
And that's why he's at the hospital.
I took away too much of his spinal fluids.
Uh, Lord Kurosis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, but what about, like...
I dropped.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, let's try the storm throw.
And you call us...
You guys are the ones that want to fucking buy his business.
Like, pieces of his disc.
I'm out of the freak.
Yeah, I got the admin.
I just wanted to sell it as a joke.
I didn't actually want to sell it.
It was a hee-hee-ha-ha joke.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
There's a cameraman.
What's that?
A toad is stuck on a cloud over in Cloud Cap?
Oh, of course they are.
Around here.
Everyone needs to be more careful around here.
Us Locky Toos can't save everyone.
Listen, if you want me to save him, you're gonna need to cough up 500...
Nah, it's fine.
Are you desperate to get him saved?
I'm sure Princess Daisy can lend him a hand after her cap challenge.
Although, I wouldn't be happy waiting that long if I were...
No, I'm not paying $500.
No.
I mean, there's so many toads here.
Like...
Like, we can replace...
How...
We can literally grab a toad and be like, congratulations, you're Captain Toad.
Like, that can't be his fucking name.
Captain Toad?
He has not trademarked Captain Toad.
I'll just grab a random toad and give him a hat.
Hey, Mario.
It's me.
Photo.
One picture taken for your time.
Yeah, I do.
Great, why don't you stand over there?
Perfect.
Now, how about a Super Mario Super Jump for the camera?
Your photo's uploading.
Check it later.
Just go to my account, photocap.bluesky.social.
Daisy's love battling with ground-type capture.
I've seen people bring nearby Typhoon to hit him with super effective moves and Toadie the Dodger attacks.
Thanks for letting me know.
All right.
I'm wearing pants under my grass skirt in case it flies off in the wind.
What kind of pants?
Laminated demnum.
All right.
Nice.
So you'll see my picture in that social media post.
All right.
Yeah.
Please heal them.
Trip, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
Boss, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know that bombs learn an explosion at level 34?
Don't believe it?
Look up your...
Don't...
It's like...
Did you know that bomb inflation is real?
Look it up.
Yeah.
The way it says that.
Okay.
Fudgetop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fine.
But the long goose have something already.
Can we suck it?
Yeah, you can.
Just stick a straw into their neck and go...
It's like...
Or you can suck it off through other...
It's like combing separate dad's...
Spinal fluid.
Please don't.
What?
Long goose, explain.
What happened?
What happened to my beautiful airship?
First of all, orange, yellow, and green is not intimidating.
Wait, but he's orange, yellow, and green.
Secondly, how can a propeller moving that slow get any lift?
And worst of all, I don't see my awesome face anywhere.
Do I have to save Captain Toad?
Can I just defeat Daisy and then she'll save him for me?
Mario!
I'm not surprised my cronies couldn't hold you back.
You better be prepared.
Because Kamek and I have been talking about strategy.
This pyre star is mine!
Breakfast.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Merchant idea.
Dad build a bear-ass plush, but instead of the heart that goes in...
It's a vial of the fluid.
Guys, I don't know how big you think a fucking vial is.
It's not that big.
It's like those tiny ass, like, like, like those, like, you know, surgical vials, guys.
It's not like a fucking jar of spinal fluid.
Okay, let's see.
Mecha Koopa.
Let's try Spark.
Oh my god, it's the Mecha Koopas.
I hated those in the Super Mario.
And that...
Which one?
Which game was it?
I played it on stream before, too.
Oh my god!
No, he can't be paralyzed again!
Please, I don't have 10k!
I do, but I can't afford another 10k.
Oh, it has lightning rod.
I'm so dumb.
Yeah, Super Mario move.
Alright.
Alright, there you go.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, I can use Spark on this one.
Don't worry, he'll heal himself.
I believe in him.
Oh my god, I'm confused and paralyzed!
Oh wait, not me.
Dad is.
Oh my god.
Another 10k down the drain.
At least there's free healthcare in Toad World.
Oh, he's about to use Bowser.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
I'll fight him.
You know what?
I'm gonna chuck you.
Alright.
What's he gonna do?
Kill me?
Yeah, there you go.
I'm not confused anymore.
Okay, that is pretty strong.
Wait, that's my strong...
No, Vite of Throw is my strongest move.
Alright, at least I'm not confused.
That is strong.
Alright, you know what?
I'll end it with Flame Wheel.
One of every move.
He'll live.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
He'll live.
He'll live this up.
Next.
Do you only have one move?
Is this your struggle?
He literally has one move.
Nice.
Yeah.
Leveled up.
Drag one leveled up too.
Not even close.
Washer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bottle, tap, water, call it, tax, put, sell it, and donate the proceeds to Adam's.
I think I'd actually get like called by like an inspector or something.
Like someone's gonna fucking report me and be like, this person's trying to sell their dog's spider flute.
Please like, like the, the, what was it?
The, there's like the pet society or whatever's gonna come up.
Be like, we have reports that you're selling your dog's spider fluids.
I'm going straight to the next one.
Your Highness, I have prepared, please scouted the ship.
This pirate star will be.
Mario!
What are you doing here?
I see.
My liege has made an expedited but tactical retreat.
Wait, wait for me!
Alright, let's go heal real quick.
Yeah.
Not Pita.
Pita doesn't do jack shit.
Also like, Pita is not a good org in general.
All they do is just rage bait.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, chatreflexstreamer.
Thank you for the super chat, Anton.
Thank you, thank you.
There's like a Canadian pet society.
Can pet humane society?
I'll press it.
I like pressing buttons.
Woo-hoo!
Oh yeah, let me hear it.
Daisy!
Mario!
It's about time you showed up.
Welcome aboard the Cloud Cutter.
My air shape and striker stadium.
We're gonna have lots of fun fighting for your power star.
She'll look better if she was an elephant.
Not gonna...
Guys, I've heard about the elephant, man.
Now then.
For those who don't know, there's this guy who goes...
Anytime someone posts art of Daisy, this guy goes over and commissions them to draw an elephant version of them.
And like, I can't tell if it's a fetish or if it's like...
If it's like some meme thing that he's doing for content.
Are we ready for a game?
Wait, what?
Listen up, Mario.
Do whatever it takes to get a bullet built into the goal.
And you better not come complaining to me if you can't figure it out.
Okay.
Okay, so obviously I have to do that.
Alright.
Whoops.
Um.
Wait, I can't hit anything now.
Struggling, are we?
No, I just can't hit anything.
Alright, don't worry.
Wait, this is a ground type.
I'll just throw it.
Wait, he used protect...
PUSSY!
Oh, and I heard him.
Oh my god.
It's because I touched him.
Don't worry.
I'll still chuck you.
That's right.
I don't care.
PUSS, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Time to fund for...
We need to multiply the long goons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, have you ever tried throwing a cactus?
What?
He has gloves on.
I saw him have a glove on.
It's not like he can't fucking...
Like...
It's not gonna hurt his hands if he's gloved up.
All right.
We don't need for a re-attack.
He got one mon?
What are you doing, you failure?
Yeah, I know.
You can do it, Ma.
Pay attention.
Yeah, but I can't...
Oh, wait.
I still can.
Okay.
I was gonna say, why can't I hit these anymore?
Obviously...
We need to figure out how to get rid of this one.
Okay.
That's how.
And then...
There we go.
And I do this.
I figured out the puzzle.
It's not that hard.
Yeah!
I expected no less from you, Mario.
Let's hurry up and battle.
Daisy!
So easy.
I should have healed Dad.
All right.
It's time to throw a cactus.
Wait.
I could burn the cactus.
What am I fucking doing?
It's grass.
What am I going to do?
What the fuck am I doing?
It's a goddamn cactus.
How am I hurt?
Oh, it charged in flame.
Okay.
It's fine.
All right.
Tweester?
Who's tweester?
Oh, it's a twister.
Oh!
I mean...
I'm gonna...
You know what?
I'm gonna throw a twister.
I'm a hurricane chaser.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm...
Doesn't matter.
I chase hurricanes.
Go to the eye of the storm.
I should...
Okay.
He's gonna live.
Oh, and I'm trapped by the sand tomb.
Oh.
Okay.
That's okay.
I believe in you, tragoon.
It's time...
It's time to lick the twister.
Oh, wait.
It's not that effective.
It's okay.
Stop looking at us.
Why don't...
Keep licking!
Lick the twister.
Nice.
Toki, please switch the tragoon out.
All right.
Monty Mole.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wait, I can use water.
Who has a...
Okay.
Progoon.
It's time.
Use your fishy powers.
All right.
Bubble beam.
Oh my God.
It's your time.
Who would have thought water is strong against ground type?
Who would have thought type advantages?
You're gonna dig a fucking hole, you coward?
Get out of here!
Fight me like a mod!
What does it really matter?
He's gonna fucking dig.
Like...
I have to wait until he comes back.
All right.
It's time to take a bath.
Yeah!
Easy.
Level up.
Oh my God.
I won without using dad.
What is that?
No!
I wanted to win!
It's too late, Daisy.
You're not the main character.
Game, set, and match!
And our winner is...
Mario!
And I believe this trophy goes to you.
Mario received the Cloud Kingdom Power Star!
Yippee!
Let's try to try it harder, Daisy.
Your second Power Star from yours truly.
I know.
Bask in its glory.
But not for too long.
Because I have something else to award you.
Yay!
I got TM16!
I'll never use.
Because I never use TM moves.
Thanks for pulling along, Mario.
Tell your brother I'll be waiting for him.
What's that?
You need me to go pick up a stuck toad and cloud cap?
Sure thing!
Yay!
I did it!
I picked him up.
That's it?
You better not press this again.
Oh my God.
See, I didn't have to pay him.
Look at that.
I didn't have to pay him.
Man, Princess Daisy is so cool.
Her part in the cap channel isn't sure to be extreme.
But that didn't even have to pay.
Extreme, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
After the Mario Wonder Direct, I measured how much time it took for the first spicy elephant Daisy art to hit the internet.
It took nine minutes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean?
What was the first spicy elephant heart of Daisy?
Daisy.
You're right.
Kind of slow.
It should have been one minute.
Alright.
Wait, is that...
Oh my gosh.
I have to turn this.
It has to be a faster way...
To get down, right?
I do have to get Toadie, though.
I need to catch a Toadie.
There's a Toadie.
Stop giving me Toadie.
I need Toadie.
Oh, there's Toadie.
Alright.
I'm gonna catch a Toadie.
Get you in, Drago.
It's time to do more licking.
That's the only move you'll use throughout this run.
I love it.
I love whenever she looks at me like that.
It makes me so happy.
It's time to lick the Toad.
I'm so tired.
Lick the Toad, Drago.
Lick him.
Alright.
Time to catch.
Yeah.
Alright.
Who wants to be Toadie?
Toadie was caught.
Yeah.
A Koopa that learned flight through magical means.
It spends most of its time studying and become a full magic Koopa and kidnapping baby.
Wait.
Where did I...
What?
He kidnaps babies?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Who wants to be a baby kidnapper?
Who...
Who wants to be a baby kidnapper, guys?
From Yoshi's Island?
Oh, I never played Yoshi's...
You guys can tell I sort of, like, have very limited, uh, Mario experience.
Who has not...
Who has not been...
Who has not been named yet?
Alright.
Who said no?
Smug.
Goon.
You're gonna be a baby kidnapper.
Smug.
Goon.
Just for that.
You're hiding something, I can tell.
I...
You're hiding a deep, dark secret.
I know what you are.
Officer, it's that guy.
You're a baby kidnapper.
Alright.
I don't want to go through the grass here since we just defeated him.
Ohhhh.
I need to...
I need to go home.
Which one was home?
No, it's not this one.
Oh my god.
I don't know how the hole...
I think I missed the hole like five times.
This is...
Okay.
Whoops.
Alright.
I want...
Actually...
Let me...
Let me check my thing.
Okay.
So I have...
What are my types for these guys?
I have dark, steel, water, normal, grass.
Okay.
I rather keep...
Dark or steel?
Uh...
Mmm...
Sorry, Nexy.
I'm swapping you out for flying.
I'm swapping you out.
I forgot I made this.
I'm swapping you...
How does it feel to be swapped for a baby napper?
Ah...
Ok.
Let's see.
We'll go back.
Mario!
There you are!
Who said that?
Oh, it's Professor.
Oh...
Caught up to you again!
You're really making quick work of these worlds.
Hey, boy.
At least I know I can always catch you at the warp zone next to you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I had a good run.
Hey, boy.
Speaking of, the topic of warp zone is precisely why I'm here.
I want you to have this, Mario.
Well, I got the warp pipe.
What does it do?
That's right.
There is a portable warp pipe.
It'll take you to a warp zone of any place that has one.
Knowing that, I can even take you to places without a warp zone.
Aren't my inventions just wonderful?
Anyways, do you know where you're going next?
I hear that words from both World 3 and 4 are up and running.
Choose whichever you like.
Oh, so I can just travel anywhere now.
Yeah, take me to World 3.
Cafe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Excited to see you when I go to Phantom Man and Off Kai this year.
I plan to attempt a makeshift cosplay, so I hope I can get it by then.
Also, why would I be potentially thrown into the isekai?
Maybe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Meanwhile...
Oh, where's Bowser going?
So Mario thinks he can beat us by going to World 3 first?
Ha!
He doesn't know that World 4 is quicker to go through.
He's gonna be mighty surprised when he returns, Kamek!
Yes, your ugliness?
Destroy this warp pipe.
With gusto, my liege.
Wait, I can just use my...
What do you do?
Bwahaha!
Kamek!
Oh, where's to World 4?
Wait, but he just destroyed it.
Kamek?
Yes, my horridness.
Parody airship for World 4.
Yeah, he just plugged it up.
Where's like my...
Isn't this place guarded by toads?
What did the princess pay you for?
Okay, so...
Like, what's the point of having a princess if like...
Having a job here if you don't do your job?
War pipe.
List, okay.
Oh, I have to be there already.
Okay, so that's my fly move.
Oh, I see.
So, instead of having regular fly, I just have that.
Okay, I just thought I could go through here for something.
What was that?
9,999.
10,000.
All powered up.
Peridotty?
What are you?
What the fuck is that?
Cat.
Cat quack.
Cat-a-quack.
Oh, that's cute.
Let's throw it.
Yeah, me too.
What is that?
Like, who is that?
What game is he from?
Mario Sunshine?
Maybe I should try Mario Sunshine one day.
Never played Mario Sunshine before.
Well, he's dead now.
Mario...
Bowser literally did something Jokey would accidentally do.
Thank you for the Super Chat Darkblade.
Thank you, thank you.
A game I really want to play is...
Um, I want to play Epic Mickey.
After I finish one game.
Like, after I finish Dynasty Warriors, I want to play Epic Mickey.
Or this one.
Whichever first.
I can't hit that?
What's the point?
It's just a block.
Oh my god, he's angry.
Wait, isn't that from...
What the fuck?
I'm gonna catch the sun.
Alright, you know what to do.
Try good.
It's time.
It's time to lick the sun.
I'm gonna make you lick the sun.
No.
Praise the sun.
Lick the sun.
Oh my god.
Wait, it does no damage.
Okay.
Okay, I'll stop licking the...
Why not swallow the sun?
Now it's time to bite the sun.
That's right.
Ooh.
Lick that sun.
Keep biting harder.
Oh shit.
Oh, you're not dead.
Okay, that's good.
Alright, now I can catch you.
Swallow the sun.
Alright, cafe.
I'll name you after the angry sun.
Nice.
Number 18.
Wow.
Why is he angry?
He's just angry, guys.
Bro, he's only...
Bro, he's 400.
Oh my god.
He's only 339 pounds.
Bro, he's a fucking giant star.
He's only six foot tall?
That's a tiny...
Son.
Tiny, short sun.
Short king.
Alright.
Let's see.
Cafe...
Oh shit.
Goon.
Ew.
Stop shaming the sun.
That's why he's angry.
Oh wait, it's cat-a-quack!
Time to lick him.
Okay.
You should...
I think Dragoon should stop.
Wait, actually no.
It's time to lick the sun.
Again!
Oh shit.
Okay, maybe not.
Maybe not.
You're about to die.
Who's the weakest?
Okay, I'll put Hefligoon.
Now we are sun-shaming?
Dang.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it's not very effective.
Okay.
We'll just use tackle.
Um...
Memonto.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you like rage-quitting games in Mario Sunshine, maybe for you.
It's actually pretty tough for a Mario game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's a kid's game.
How bad can it be?
I say as I rage-quitted multiple children games.
Bro, what the fuck?
You're so weak, Hefli.
Guess who's gonna get replaced soon?
Now that I realize how weak you are...
Alright, let's see.
You pointed against the fighting.
How was I supposed to know he could fight?
It's a...
Look at him!
Alright.
All right, let's just try catching him.
What the fuck?
Bro, why is he so strong?
Okay, I'll bite you.
I have to like...
Jesus Christ!
All right, maybe he'll be...
It's only limbs or legs, which means they're...
Yeah, but he has... Look at his mouth!
Why can't he lick?
Oh, goodbye.
Everything for Cataquack.
Okay.
All right, Husky.
He can't punch...
What's he gonna punch a plant?
Stun him.
Okay, how do I miss that?
Yes.
He's gonna punch a plant.
Okay, now he's done.
Jesus, this is like the hardest one...
I've had to like capture lately.
Bump.
All right, who wants to be Cataquack?
He killed Prog Wound.
All right, a large round creature with beak.
It enjoys fighting, flinging things or people into the air.
Most always water fighting.
Most are timid and will not approach strangers unprovoked.
All right.
Let's see.
Cataquack.
Someone who is not me.
I...
All right.
Water.
Water fighting.
I think it's only natural.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
Duck.
Thank you.
Super chat.
You're right.
You're actually right.
You should be the duck one.
Duck.
Uh...
Goon.
All right.
Perfect.
Into the Pokemon.
Wait.
Actually, I need to...
I need to know how to...
Learn how to use this more effectively.
There you go.
I gotta warp back.
Castle Gardens.
Peaches Castle.
Uh...
Toe Town.
Yeah.
Let's go to Toe Town.
I gotta heal.
A lot of you guys are fucked up right now.
Yay!
The map looks really cool.
Wait.
Can I, like, warp back to there?
I wonder.
Oh, I can.
Yeah, because I start...
No, I can't?
Oh.
I thought I could.
How many worlds do we...
Okay, we have one, two, three...
I assume...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Oh, there's Rainbow Road!
I assume this is, like...
After credits, right?
Yeah, Rainbow Road.
It has to be, like...
Uh, Game Plus.
Alright.
Down I go.
Back here.
Oh!
What am I gonna counter?
Oh my god, it's Cataquac.
I'm gonna...
Actually, no.
Cataquac is very annoying to fight.
I don't wanna deal with Cataquac.
I'll fight you.
All the bugs love me!
Okay, Johnny Bravo.
Would like to fight?
Oh my god.
Aw, look!
They're your children!
I'm gonna burn them.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Yeah?
All your children loves you.
It would be a shame if I...
Fucking burn them all.
Goodbye.
Oh!
Don't worry, he just fainted.
I tell them, as his...
His children are burnt to crisp.
Not a sociopath or anything.
Oh god, I hate that.
I hate that one.
That's so...
I don't know.
It just makes me uncomfortable.
Like, she's just...
Like...
Like, it's coming out...
She's just standing there looking at me like that.
It's just so uncomfortable.
Yeah, fainted with third degree burn.
That's true.
Oh my god, it's a granite!
It's the little guys in Super Mario World!
Sorry, I had to hydrate.
Alright.
Smogoon!
My boy!
He grew at level 13!
Alright, that one was easy.
Okay, I'm gonna check if there's any more...
That I can catch.
Is there any more?
No, it's all cat-a-quack.
God, no one loves you!
Get out!
Alright, I'll do one more.
Let's see if there's any.
What the fu- What the fu- Oh!
He looks like the...
He looks like the Pikmin dogs!
Oh, he's cute!
I think he's cute.
Alright.
Can't be that bad.
Oh, I'm a water type now.
That's a natural.
I don't like it.
Okay, well...
Oh, soup- Oops, I forgot he's water type!
Well, goodbye.
What the fu- What did he do to me?
Okay.
Um, well...
Let's see if we can catch him again.
Okay, now it's just all cat-a-quack.
Oh, it fucking died.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Guess I just killed it.
And he like...
What the fu- Wait, I recognize him!
Alright, let's put Dragoon out there.
Okay, wait, okay.
Let me not put Dragoon out there.
I'll put Progoon.
That guy's like...
It's like Diglett!
But bigger!
And he's like a bigger Diglett.
Well, obviously, he's gonna be high.
I'll just...
I don't know how strong he is.
Bubblica...
Bubbl...
Bubbles?
Bubbles!
Sir, welcome to the...
To the hand farm!
Welcome, welcome!
It's a chunky Diglett.
Let me bite...
Oh, I missed.
Alright.
Bite him!
Bite the Diglett!
Not so Deadpool!
Thank you for the fire!
Give the ships!
Thank you the...
How do I miss every bite?
I don't understand!
Oh my god, I didn't kill him.
Thank God!
I'm sorry!
Okay, my...
My fish might be a little blind.
Because he's not in water and slowly dying.
What about the air?
Yay!
Alright, who wants to be...
What's his name?
Minion!
A servant of a snake king.
The length of its body is unknown.
It is said to train its balance for decades.
In order to balance plates and bowls in its head.
Okay.
So he's useless.
If that's all he does...
Oh my god, look at him.
Haha!
Look at his face!
Alright.
Alright, you know what?
I'll use the first person.
Uh...
Red.
Goon.
That's the first person I saw in my chat.
Red.
Goon.
There we go.
Oh, it is a long...
It's a super long goon.
Alright, let's see.
Where are my...
Are my mons okay?
Oh, yeah.
They're fine.
They're so fine.
Okay.
There's one more.
I'll catch one more.
No!
Get out of cat!
Nobody loves you!
Get out of my lobby!
Alright.
The ancient lunk.
Oh my god!
Leave!
I will make sure your con is extinct if I get you again.
You're here.
The angry son.
Oh my god, he's so angry.
Bunch of quacks.
I know.
I'll make fog raw out of you.
That's right.
Oh, that's it.
That's fucking it.
I'm angry now.
I know you can't just kick a grass.
Toki can't just say that.
That's right.
Wait, I don't have any...
Oh, I do.
I was like, wait.
I don't have any grass moose.
That's right.
Fine, whip.
And I'll do it again!
Get fog rod!
Yeah!
Alright, I'll do one more.
If I don't see the chunky boy, I leave.
God damn it.
It's all cataracts.
This ecosystem.
It's an invasive species.
I refuse to believe they are not an invasive species.
Wait, there's a toad.
Oh, it's not friendly.
It could work in a break.
Sailor...
Pormeline.
I would like to battle.
Wait, he has six?
Oh my god!
They're all babies!
I'm gonna throw the baby.
I'm gonna throw the baby!
Eat the baby.
Yeah!
I'm level 23.
Alright.
Shroob.
Where's Shroob?
Oh my god.
Wait, what happened to that toad?
Is that like...
Is that like a Last of Us situation?
Is that...
Is that Clicker?
Alright.
I'm gonna throw him too.
I throw all the babies.
Nothing is safe.
That's right.
Get thrown.
Red, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for making me the Red Goon.
Hopefully the box is nice and comfy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, there's a lot of things happening in that box.
I hope you enjoy it.
Oh my god!
That's him!
I didn't get to kill...
I didn't get to catch him!
Because I didn't get to catch him, I shall kill him.
Yay!
Oh!
Whoop, he's a little hurt.
What else?
Okay, let me heal dad real fast.
Alright, it's fine.
I can heal him.
Uh...
Where's my items?
Super Shroom!
I have enough.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
I saw you open your tweet about the P.O.
box.
Would you be interested in having a physical copy of the tabletop care sheet I made you yesterday?
If so I can get...
Yeah, no problem.
You can send whatever you want.
Um...
This is the P.O.
box.
Of course.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's what your P.O.
box is for.
For you guys to send stuff to me if you want.
What?
Get out of here.
You're not even a challenge.
Look how big and strong dad is.
Embargo?
What's that?
Oh.
That's not a...
That's not a fight item.
Get out of here.
You're not learning, dad.
Alright.
Beanie.
Oh god.
It's the guy in the corner.
Uh.
Darkblade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Today I learned.
Joki and Toadie apparently share a hatred for babies.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, no, no.
I throw everybody.
Equal rights for everyone.
What the fuck is that?
It's like a larvae for a fly.
A Jabba.
Wait.
What game is that from?
What a sweat!
Nice.
I mean, he was the first guy...
Oh my god, Husky Goon!
You're evolving!
What do you turn into?
Husky Goon is evolving!
Oh!
Is that the little guys at the bottom?
Yes!
Those guys!
Congratulations!
Your Husky Goon evolved into a munchie!
Yes, those little guys at the bottom!
They can't touch!
Trying to jar lock.
Okay.
Is it a good...
prevents the user and the target?
Oh, it's 80!
Wait, that's good.
Alright, get the snap tree out of here.
Snap trap out of here.
Munch, munch!
Yum yum yum yum yum!
Yeah!
Okay, you're not learning embargo.
Stop trying to learn embargo.
This is like the third time you try to learn it.
I told you!
Mama's not letting you learn embargo!
You're only damage!
That's all you're good for!
You're not going to diamond city that easily!
Send out Buzzy B!
Okay.
I'm gonna throw you.
Okay, flame.
I forgot.
What is he?
He was dark type, right?
Oh no, he's gonna curse me.
Wait, you speed attack?
Alright, there you go.
Yeah!
That's right.
You think you can beat me?
And dad?
That's the only one that's actually been fighting!
Oh, he's actually weak to fighting?
I like how I didn't use fighting when I have two fighting moves.
Goddammit!
I don't want you!
Get out of here!
Get out!
Okay, I have the bros bean.
Huh.
Is this the right way?
We lost.
I feel like...
I should be able to break these blocks, right?
Or...
Am I allowed to break those?
Goddammit!
Get out!
I don't want you here, Catterquack!
I should be able to break these, right?
Or no?
I can't tell.
Am I allowed to break these?
Because they're everywhere!
They're an invasive species!
They're like iguanas!
We're legally allowed to eat iguanas now!
Because they're an invasive species in Florida.
Okay, let's see.
Maybe he'll be back.
Maybe a big boy...
Oh my god, there's another Catterquack.
No, they're not.
No, they're not!
Mario brought him over!
Mario loves to talk big!
Especially like he owns Diamond City!
We've got friends everywhere with connections to all sorts of things!
Wait, Wario's in this game?
Oh my god, that means Waluigi's in here!
Wah!
Oh my god, the main character is in this game!
I can't wait!
If there's Wadio, there's Waluigi!
The actual main characters!
Wah!
The character that matters the most!
Waluigi!
Maoshi!
When will I have Year of Waluigi?
The beach holds tons of secrets!
Don't be afraid to dig in the sun or poke around the walls!
Oh, I got a big pearl!
How do I dig?
I don't have that.
I remember when...
My cock limbs had something shimmering.
A moss hardened a scale value of 10.
Cubic crystal structure unlike any other.
Nice!
I got a scuba cap!
Every year is Year of Waluigi so true!
Isn't the beach beautiful?
The sand is also a really nice temperature!
It's nice!
Nice.
My mind is a temple and a steel trap!
No one can ever learn in secrets!
How'd I become so zen?
This training module for impression taught me everything!
And now I don't need it anymore!
Nice.
I got TM.
You see it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're so zen, guys.
I'm so zen!
He's zen.
Warrior has the strongest...
That was the strangest food request tonight!
He asked for a fresh corn seed garlic!
I don't know what that is, so...
I'm here to pretend I'm picking up whatever that is!
Good job, dude.
I knew I could count on you.
Alright.
Look, there's pearls here, alright?
Big pearls equals big money.
Enjoying the beauty of War 3-1?
Between the ocean, Diamond City, Skyline, there's a lot to see!
Nice.
Alright, let's see.
Ever take a moment to sit down and breathe?
Rest up?
Let it be now.
Oh, nice.
He's healing me.
Nice.
Thank you, old man.
I won't step on you.
Don't worry.
Because you healed me, I shall now refrain from stepping on you and killing you.
Cause I'm a nice guy.
Thanks, old man.
God dammit, I wanna fight that big...
Big boy!
Let me...
Let me fight that big boy and let me enslave him in my...
In my Pokeball!
Yay!
Alright.
Water versus water.
Doki.
He's back!
Alright.
Bubble versus Bubble.
Run, little guy.
You're going to my PC.
The...
Oh wait, it's definitely not effective.
Look, I just thought since we're both...
We're both water...
Wait, he does so much on...
Okay.
It's cause...
Okay, that makes sense though.
Cafe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for making me the angry son.
I shall enjoy the box of the goons doing angry things for the rest of my days.
Well, back to the grind.
Thank you for the super chat, Cafe.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, who wants to be my strolling?
They see him strolling.
They hating.
To the box with ya!
A tropical cousin to the Goomba that loves to swim and sunbathe.
Oh, you're like above a Goomba.
You have just a little bit more rights than him.
It wears a bathing suit to the beach because it has amazing...
Wait, amazing?
Wait, does that mean Goombas are purposely naked?
It's a choice?
You think Goombas are naked as a choice?
Oh, yeah.
Like, strolling is like, wear his clothes because it's black.
Whoa.
Alright, who wants to be a strolling?
It's a tactic of...
What's the tactics to be naked?
I...
What's the tactics there?
Alright.
Let's see...
I'm already forgetting which one I...
Like, who are in the box right now.
I haven't looked at them in a long time.
It's been...
Husky, thank you for the aca, Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Shul and Stu is my little baby.
Here's an aca for giving him a home.
Yes, the PC dungeon counts.
Thank you for the aca, Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Let me be Stu, please.
Okay, because you said, please, I'll let you be Stu.
Alright.
Let's see.
Snaz goon.
Snaz.
Because you were polite just like this...
Just like the strolling for wearing clothes.
There you go.
Snaz goon.
Oh, he's out of the car.
Woah, woah, woah!
I'm practicing my drifts!
Alright.
Oh my god!
Bro!
That's cool.
Woah, he's so cool.
He's drifting, buddy.
Look at him drift.
Damn.
Oh my god, he's Akira drifting.
Tokyo Drift.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can I join the PC?
Don't worry, you'll be named next.
Whichever...
Whichever one...
New Mon I encounter, you get the next name, Mike.
It'll be very unfortunate though.
Whichever...
Oh, that's the best part about the RNG of it too.
You don't know which one I'm gonna encounter next.
That's new.
It could be anyone.
Yeah.
Diamond City is the perfect target.
They're already so busy with Wario.
I'll never suspect another thief.
Yeah.
Let's go gambling!
What if I just name you after?
What if I just go back and find...
That one guy.
You know that guy I'm talking about.
I have three of them.
I need more.
I need two more.
The pinata sleeps peacefully in the cliff side.
Sleep talk?
Which capture?
Wait, what?
Able to what?
Alright, who am I giving up?
Okay.
Alright, Brogoon.
Oh!
Sleep talk.
Oh no.
You're not learning that.
We don't need that.
Hey, heading to Diamond City?
It's just over there.
I'm just growing a little garden away from the hustle and bustle of the city.
Okay.
Is it here?
You should check out the purple areas or the WarioWare Inc.
Oh!
It's the WarioWare!
Welcome to Diamond City!
Hey, wait a minute.
You seem to be one of those people who are competing in the current challenge for PyroStars.
Am I correct?
In that case, mind if I ask you a few things for the show I'm doing?
Great!
Let's get started then!
Oh!
What do I feel like?
Where's my miss?
I feel...
Why?
Great!
Thanks a lot, Mario!
Oh, wow!
I didn't realize it was you!
Although, I guess the overalls and mustache should have given away.
But last I made that mistake, ended up being a brother Luigi!
Well, I hope you enjoy your stay in Diamond City, Mario!
Why?
Why am I here?
What is my purpose?
Pitchville!
Viva!
I'm loving it!
Nice, good for you.
Alright, talk to me, Toad.
I'll stop you right here.
Whee!
There sure is a lot of different environments in Diamond City for me to play in!
Hey!
You looking to get around Diamond City?
The DCL Diamond City lift can help you for the cost of just 500 quarts!
How big is...
There's a daycare!
Wait...
Oh, no!
The beach provides good resistance training for the annual Diamond City Triathlon!
Oh, I found a daycare, guys!
I...
Wait, no, that's just a garden!
Goddammit!
Yeah!
Hey there!
Feeling lost in Big City?
Well, don't worry!
We're offing free...
Oh, nice!
Oh!
I'm a Yoshi!
Oh my god!
Look at him go!
Have you heard of a Yoshi whistle?
I'll let you ride a Yoshi anytime you want!
I don't think they're offered anywhere here in Diamond City, though.
Wait, where do I get a Yoshi whistle?
I want a Yoshi whistle!
Look at him go!
Whee!
I need to find this daycare, guys.
That's like our first mission in life.
Hey there!
New to Diamond City?
I recommend checking out the various signs or talking to the toads and carts.
The city is way too big and confusing.
You're new around here.
So don't be afraid to ask for help.
I talked to any of these?
Mario Games Studio makes some questionable video games.
I thought he was making something to rival Pydomon.
But I just know it's going to be a bad knockoff.
Oops, sorry.
That's not what I want.
I love Diamond...
I love Diamond City!
But I don't think it's the same about Diamond Suburbs!
Cities are engines of creativity and wealth creation.
And low-density suburbs or conserves exist to extract that wealth then use it to support wasteful, inefficient, and environmentally harmful lifestyles!
Read it out!
What the fuck?
I did not expect that in my Mario game.
Want me to crash...
Wait, okay.
Let's...
Let's save it.
All right.
Before we crash the game, let me save this game real fast.
Sure.
Well, too bad.
I don't know actually...
Okay, I don't actually know how to.
How do you...
Okay, you know what?
How much money do I have?
Oh, I have enough.
It's fine.
Let's go to the daycare.
I'm the daycare man.
I'll take care...
You like me to raise your captures?
Have a word with the woman.
It's time.
Yes.
All right.
We're shooting this stuff.
Okay, so we need the mail.
What do we need more?
No.
Wait.
Let's...
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
You know what?
All right.
Let's put...
We'll put you in custody.
Let's see.
I would like...
Gus.
All right.
Let's put you here for now.
And then...
Wait.
Was that male?
Oh, wait.
It has to be female.
I forgot.
You're lucky today.
You're so lucky today.
All right.
We'll put John.
And then...
Also, we need Gus in here.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, Gus.
Gus.
You'll have a good time.
Oh, but don't worry.
It's not gonna ruin anything.
Because I still have these two.
All right.
Let's put Gus in here.
Wait.
Chosen.
How do I choose?
Okay.
Yes.
Oh, race.
Come back to the little.
He can race too.
Yes.
All right.
Hello, Gus and John.
I hope you have fun in there.
All right.
They'll have lots of fun.
No.
Don't take me off the couch.
Gus.
Thank you for the magenta sofa.
Thank you.
It's too late, Gus.
It's too late.
Cosmic.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you guys having fun?
Oh.
The two prefer to play with other captures than each other.
You guys are not compatible.
All right.
You're lucky.
You're not compatible.
You're so lucky.
All right.
We need another male in there.
You know what?
E-Dragon.
You're getting lucky tonight.
Oh, wait.
You're still dead.
I forgot.
I forgot you.
I killed you.
It's okay.
You'll be back to normal.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about that.
It was so long ago.
Yes.
I'll take away.
What am I taking away?
I'm taking away.
What's so...
Who...
It was Gus, right?
Yeah.
It was Gus.
Yes.
All right.
Give me back Gus.
No.
Yes.
I need to erase my...
My dead...
Dragoon.
All right.
No!
Is it because he's dead?
Is it...
Don't worry.
I'll find...
We have lots of options.
We have...
All right.
Goodbye Gus.
Don't worry.
We have...
Oh my God.
You need...
You need a...
Need a bean in your life?
Is that it?
I need...
John...
Is that...
Don't worry.
I have a bean in here too.
One of them will work.
I have smurf goon.
One of you will be satisfied.
All right.
Who am I taking?
I was taking the dragon.
Okay.
Yeah.
We'll find you that special goon.
Don't worry.
I'll find you your special goon.
Oh wait.
You're back to life.
All right.
Maybe you'll love each other now.
What?
What is your compatibility rate?
Why won't you love?
I need to find your true love.
What do you love?
What will you love?
This goon is really picky.
I'll find your true love.
Don't worry.
All right.
We have a lot of options.
We have two...
We have three more...
Two more options.
We have...
Tips and Alan.
One of them will love each other.
I believe.
I'm not giving up.
I'll find love for you.
I'll use my entire money.
I'll find you love.
If it's the last day I do.
Don't worry.
You will find love.
All right.
No.
Okay.
All right.
Does he love?
No!
You still don't have love in your heart!
I don't understand!
There's so many suitors!
I'm literally playing like that.
You know that dating show?
With like one...
One woman and a hundred guys.
And then they give a rose?
I'm doing that right now.
Like I...
I'm...
This is...
This is what I'm doing right now.
Yeah.
This is the Bachelorette.
Right now.
With fucking John.
We're doing the Bachelorette.
Yeah.
All right.
Actually, we'll try to rock first.
Maybe he'll like rocks.
I don't know.
We're trying to find a perfect match.
All right.
Tips.
You go in there.
All right.
Are you found love?
No!
Still nothing!
Why?
Why don't you like anything?
Don't worry.
Okay.
No.
Wait, wait.
We still have one more.
Our Hail Mary.
We have...
Alan.
If you don't fall in love...
Then it's hopeless.
You were never meant to fall in love.
You were never meant to find anybody.
Okay.
Our last Hail Mary.
All right.
Alan.
Go in there.
Show him.
Show him what love is.
No!
John, you're gonna die alone.
I'm sorry, John.
I have to catch more mons until you find your perfect match.
Forever alone.
Well then.
Unfortunately.
John was not satisfied.
With any of our suitors.
He has not found love.
Don't worry, John.
I will catch more.
I will find your husband though.
Don't worry.
Hehehehe.
Every Monday.
Jimmy T host Pilates at Club Sugar.
Gotta burn that weekend sweat off.
Where am I?
Hehehehe.
Like... Oh.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Oh my superstars!
I can't believe I'm talking to Mario!
Please, take a complimentary gift from the department store!
Nice.
Wait, no, isn't Maddie the female?
Did you know a place where you get some really good soup?
Asking for a friend!
I thought it was female in here.
Oh, you mean that?
Oh, wait, I could... You're right!
Wait, you're right!
You're right!
I forgot.
Maybe I was going at it all wrong.
I shouldn't have tried to intermix.
I was going at it all wrong.
Alright.
This is it.
Let's see.
Yay!
We found your true love!
Let's go!
He picked the bachelorette!
The bachelorette!
Many did it!
They found true love!
We did it, guys!
True love is real!
Oh my god, true love is real!
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I panicked, but then I realized it was John, the goon, who's laying this treatment.
Who, I dodged a bullet.
I'm looking for a gift from my grandson.
He really likes these energy drinks.
His favorite celery promotes.
But I can't seem to find it.
He talks a lot about the kiyot flavor.
No!
Not the kiyot flavor.
I don't believe it.
Oh.
I need a capture.
Is he a zebra flap?
Yeah, I wanna try.
What did I get?
29119.
Do I have any?
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Aw, we don't have any.
Who is that?
Mehdi and John are meant for each other.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This department store has everything I asked for.
Except whatever that old toad is asking for it.
Oh, the kiyot flavor.
I wonder if I should read these.
I'm a little disappointed I can't buy super barrel caps here.
It's not a big deal.
That just gives me an excuse to visit toasterina.
Alright, what do they have?
Mushrooms.
Okay, I don't need any of that.
I need more caps though.
Okay.
Higher rate.
Restores.
Better unlowered.
Oh my god, the party hat.
A cap that works better in captures recorded before.
That makes captures more friendly and fancy.
Oh my god, a fancy boy.
Okay, we'll get a baseball cap.
How much can I buy?
Seven?
Yeah.
I spent all my money.
I spent all my money right now, even though there's more to this place.
Okay, they're just talking about...
We don't need to read that.
That's not important.
I like how I spent all my money now.
Now I can't buy anything.
Whoops.
Oh, it's like the X attack and stuff.
Speed bean!
Beans are a great way to boost the effort values of captures, but they're pretty expensive.
Some people prefer reliable training over drugs.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, I can just use this over and over for EV training shit.
I don't care about that.
Hmm.
There sure are a lot of different ways the species of our world can evolve and become stronger.
But just because someone can evolve, doesn't mean that they always should.
In fact, this item here makes captures stronger.
And they're not yet at their full potential.
Here, why don't you have it?
Evil light?
What's that?
Don't worry, I have no use for that stone.
I'm not even a commander.
Oh, okay, so that's for my Yoshi's.
Oh, yeah!
We don't need any of these guys.
My Yoshi is gonna grow up big and strong.
The natural way.
Alright, let's put it on.
Let's give the item to Dad.
Since he's not fully evolved yet, right?
Yeah.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, no, no.
Get away from...
Well, I'm sorry.
You're apparently the perfect match made in heaven.
Aye, aye, aye.
What's this?
What does he sell?
Oh, he sells TMs.
How about you?
Also TMs.
I don't care about TMs, though.
Oh, nice.
Free TM.
Too bad I don't care about TMs.
I don't need to use...
I don't need to use special discs to make my mom stronger.
He's gonna be strong through the things he learned in my training.
Suffering from recess.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know what?
Make the departments are great!
A Sierra floor we can blow up!
The magic of Sierra is you're eating and drinking at the same time with one hand.
Alright, now I'm up here.
The view from here is nice, but being so high up scares me.
Sometimes it's better to just get to the ground and rest, don't you think?
I'm sure your captures would like to do so as well.
Why do I teach you how to use...
No, it's fine.
Alright, all I'm saying is that what if it was the guys that were rejecting John?
One.
And you are the only goon...
That accepted.
What if it was everyone else with very high expectations?
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Is this a gang?
Oh, they're all there.
Oh, they're all like the tower goombas.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We dodged a bullet, Toki.
Thank God.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
They're all naked on top of each other.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Where is this place?
Okay.
Alright, this is where I started.
Okay, this is where...
There's like several Pokemon centers.
Holy fuck.
Club sugar at a rental facility.
Where do I go first?
Heat all my roof, please.
I'm trying to boost my speed and HP.
Hey, you.
Where do you think you're going?
Oh, it's Ashley's house!
I don't recall any mustached individuals being invited.
I love...
I love Ashley's song.
Um, what's...
Oh my God.
There's like this cover song of Ashley's song.
And it's so good.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
It's actually one of my favorite songs.
Uh...
I need to pause just to show you guys it.
Ashley...
Ashley's song.
Uh...
Oh my God.
It's so good.
But I'm trying to remember...
Is it a jazz cover?
I'm gonna try and see.
Oh, it's a jazz cover!
Yes, this one.
I'll link it to you guys.
This one.
This is one of my favorite...
One of my favorite songs.
It's so good.
It's a jazz cover of Ashley's song.
Big street, huh?
Nice for morning walks though.
Can confirm.
There's a lot to do here in downtown.
Like going to Club Sugar.
I can't wait to see what kind of moves...
Jimmy T has cooked up for us tonight.
That's a good song.
Ba-dum-bum-bum.
Hey there.
Have you seen Jimmy T anywhere?
He's usually over here at Club Sugar right about now.
Laving up the dance floor.
I can't seem to find him today.
I'm so lost.
Who made this city?
Oh my God.
There's more?
Alright.
I'll figure this out.
My son won't look...
My son won't...
Look at me in the eye anymore.
I'm starting to drill into the gravel for oil.
It's not like the dinosaurs were using it or anything.
Sorry, I forgot it was a toad.
He used to be watching a documentary on dinosaurs.
Oh wait.
That was just him doing something.
I can't wait for my brilliant Larry Influencer to move in.
I've been following them since they were at 1.5 million.
What the fuck?
One of us.
One of us!
Is that all they say?
Is there any of them that isn't one of...
Let me go.
Let me out.
One of us!
Oh my God.
Let me out.
There's something off about here.
Like I'm always being watched or about to be part of a Xan game.
I've seen a shady city change so much over the years.
It's almost as if it doesn't have a canonical image or location.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's something for a package of long Xans.
Thank you for sacrificing your voice for toad realism.
Name of the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I definitely need it.
Since the cat challenge started, I've seen some catchers with a totally different color.
I wonder why that is.
Oh, they're talking about shinies.
Alright.
Where am I?
God, I'm so lost.
I'm so fucking lost in the city.
There's so much to do!
I don't know where to go first!
Yeah, it's me.
Oh!
Oh, no!
Get me!
Yay!
My toe, my Yoshi!
Yoshi!
That's beautiful soft sand.
Take your shoes off and relish in it.
Nice.
I got float stone.
Yay!
Hey Mario, it's me photo.
Yeah, take a photo.
Yeah!
Alright, you guys can see my photo.
Hold it on date.
The longer you live here, the more you see how weird and eccentric everyone is.
Wario isn't the mayor of Diamond City, but I love to act like he is.
Anything over here?
No.
Okay.
Where have I been?
I can't tell anymore.
Everything looks the same.
You know about Poyoro?
I heard they're making a monster tamer game based off of it.
Poyoro?
What's that?
Is that supposed to be, like, Pokemon?
My husband loves to pick things off the street.
I think it's a little gross, but it makes him happy.
Hey!
My voice says I can't keep up my fighting, so you can have this.
Nice.
I got a tiny mushroom.
I mean, you could eat it.
You don't have to, like...
You don't have to, like, give it away.
You could eat the mushroom.
It's-a me!
A Mario!
That's not the voice.
I should really stop.
Sorry, but Diamond Academy seems to be well-pired currently.
As such, the doors are stuck- stuck locked.
I need to stop.
There's too many toads!
You hear giggling inside.
The fuck is going on in that house?
Okay, I talked to her already.
Okay, at least I know who I've talked to before.
Alright.
I talked to him already.
This is new.
Okay, I'm not doing that.
Oh, they're all doing Mario Kart stuff.
Vroom vroom!
Alright, let's see.
I've been here?
Oh, what the fuck?
Who are you?
Wait, you're a human.
Hello, I'm Larry.
I run a law office here in Diamond City.
I concentrate in business law for the people of the Mushroom Kingdom.
What the fuck?
Who's Larry?
Larry?
Larry!
Larry, my goat!
What is Larry doing here?
Larry?
I was going to say it!
Why is this a human in my mind?
Larry from Pokemon?
It's just Larry?
How many jobs does he have?
What is Larry doing here?
Larry, go back to your game!
I wonder what Dr. Kragor does all the way on his little island.
What do you mean, it's just Larry?
It's the Larry!
Yeah, but what is he doing here?
This new game idea was brilliant!
Soon, I'll have everyone play my game instead of a stupid Pyromon.
I don't need a catchy name for it.
Something like Pyromon.
I got it!
Wario-mon!
Now all I need is the color of some chumps to make the game for me.
Oh my god!
It's the Wario characters!
Jimmy, how about you work on another game for me?
Groovy?
Penny, gadget's a gizmo!
Of course, Mr. Wario!
It's Ashley!
Ashley, I need you too!
She'll come through.
Wah-ha-ha!
Oh.
Three key passwords.
I want a password.
This city is so big.
Hello there, little man.
Would you like to become my minion?
Well, what if I frame you with my freeze ray?
Oh, the doctor forgot to refuel my freeze ray.
This is what I need minions for.
Little man.
I do not have, how you say, caps.
For me to recruit my own minions.
But having one will be enough.
Can you come back with a minion?
I'll trade you a capture that has been too useful for me.
Oh!
I do.
I do have one.
Don't worry.
Alright, who did I...
Who was it?
Goodbye, Red.
Don't worry.
I'll rename you.
I'll have the alternate universe of you.
Yeah.
Goodbye, Red.
7.
Goodbye.
Bye-bye, Red Goon.
Oh, that's cool.
That's funny.
He gave me a go-ba!
Alright.
Red, I would say this is like an upgrade, Red.
I...
You know?
You know, Red?
This is sort of an upgrade.
You get to be naked and free.
Little man.
You're proving your worth to me.
So we'll no longer call you.
But man in red and blue.
We will meet again.
Minion.
I have big plans for us.
Oh my god.
Goodbye, Red.
It's okay.
Oh, I can't rename you.
Oh.
Alright.
Goodbye, Red Goon.
I hope you live a beautiful life.
With this random stranger.
I hope you have a great life.
With this random man.
Goodbye.
I forgot you can't rename.
That goes right here.
And that goes over there.
Fixed.
Well done, Penny.
You got this rental facility all up and ready.
Well, I should be getting back to my lab to finish my who's-and-whats-and-a-nator.
Good luck.
Mario!
Here, how it takes to beat the rental facility?
Beat three of my robo-commanders with your holocaps to face me.
It's okay.
Red's having a good life right now.
What's this?
We're late for class.
I'll miss the box.
Red, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You get to be a minion, Red.
You get to work.
That's not too bad.
But head up to teacher's lounge right away.
Don't want to get in more trouble.
I'm a guy to the battle swap tournament.
Would you like me to take you to the chair?
We're being challenged.
I need to save data.
All right.
Here we go.
Yeah, and he has a freeze ray.
Isn't that cool?
Oh, I have to use... Oh, it's battle.
Okay.
Chubby dino capture.
Oh, my God.
We always want a baby Yoshi.
Yeah, I want you.
Duplicus?
Oh, wait.
They're so cute.
Wait, I want Duplicus.
He's cute.
Oh, he transforms into them.
And then look.
See?
Look.
There you are!
See?
Oh, in honor of you, I'll use another minion.
I'll use a minion.
Mr. Judge, you have our trust.
Oh, my God.
It's a regular person.
Swimmer.
Wait, why?
Why is, like, regular trainers here?
All right.
Oh.
Oh, this is all your moves?
Oh, I should have looked at your moves.
I should have...
I should have looked at his moves before I did anything.
I...
Oops.
All right.
It's time.
It's time, baby Yoshi.
One more stockpile.
All right.
How much can I do?
I forgot.
All right.
And then we...
We spit it out.
All right.
Spit it out!
Okay.
It's not very effective.
That's awkward.
That's...
That's pretty awkward.
All right.
Let's swap you out.
I think...
Guys, I realized maybe I should have read their moveset before I picked them up.
I just saw baby Yoshi, and I was like, I need...
I need to use it.
Whoops.
All right.
Electrify.
Come on, red.
You got this.
You're basically red.
All right.
Nice.
Yeah!
Spine.
He was...
Okay.
Let's use dive.
That's right.
I'm a coward.
I hide underwater.
I miss my mons, guys.
I hate you.
Wait, what?
That did nothing?
What?
Oh, yeah?
Can't do that if I hide underwater.
Can't do that.
That's right.
I uno reversed him.
Wait, is this Stia?
Okay, I'll sidewave it.
Surely, this is stronger, right?
Oh, it is.
Nice.
Okay, that was a lot stronger than that.
You would think that...
A move that requires two turns was stronger, but apparently not.
I'm gaming.
Sprangler.
Okay.
I'll just sidewave it.
Bugs are bad with psychic.
That's one thing I...
Okay, apparently.
Never mind.
They're just normal to it.
I don't understand.
I don't know anything about type advantages.
I don't know.
I'm like, apparently not.
Oh, it's the other way around.
Oh.
Whoops.
I was thinking of a poison.
Yeah.
It's okay.
It works.
Spamming one move always works, guys.
Thank you for competing.
Let us restore your captures.
Hey, can I, like, swap?
What is rest?
Oh, I guess I have to go on.
Yes.
Yeah, I realized baby Yoshi was not it.
Baby.
It's time to swap you.
Little spark spiny.
Okay, let's...
Oh, I can steal their...
Their mons.
You know, I'll steal your baby, son.
A baby for a baby.
Toys.
I need more toys.
It's so weird.
I'm battling, like, people.
Photographer Avery.
Alright.
Spark.
Weather ball.
I just spark.
I think spark was an attack move, right?
Yeah.
Yay!
Man vs.
Mario.
What the fuck?
A pair of bitty?
Oh, they're in Super Mario.
Uh, Sunshine.
Uh, 64, right?
These guys were in 64.
Oh, no.
Wait, that's not fair.
This is 1v3.
This is a one...
I'm a baby!
Oh, Mario 3D web?
Oh.
I was, like, 10 years short of my guess.
Maybe 15 plus.
Wait, that's a person!
What is a Lakitu doing in my...
In my mind game?
What is an actual cap...
What?
He's...
He has rights!
Doesn't he have rights?
All right.
Yeah, but I've talked to him!
He can't say that.
Not around here.
Not anymore.
I need to work for money.
What...
What are these quotes?
No.
I don't need a swap.
I'm satisfied.
Oh my god!
Big news!
It's a sand tomb!
Oh my god, it's a...
It's actually a...
An actual person from Mario.
Wait, what the fuck?
What?
And it swaps to like...
A man.
I was like...
Oh look, there's Toad!
And a man is here now.
Wait, what are my other moves?
I don't know.
Okay, electrifying.
Okay, weather bot.
Change with the weather.
Okay.
Well...
I don't know.
Maybe I should...
I should change the minion.
Because...
This should work against them, right?
Okay.
So it never failed me.
Go!
Okay, it failed me.
Okay.
Never mind.
Until now.
It failed me.
It's okay.
I can do this.
Um...
Now I don't know.
Now I...
I'll just...
I'll keep using Sidewave.
Is Dive better?
I don't know.
It feels like Dive has been like...
Fucking me up lately.
Took two turns to do absolutely nothing.
Oh wait.
That's fine.
My guy's stupid as well.
He's just been trying to use Sandstorm.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's not worth it.
I don't think it is.
That's right.
I can eat Sad.
Yum yum yum.
You trying to use Sad on me?
It fuels me.
Yum yum yum yum yum.
Oh, it's a rat.
Oh, I stole it?
Oh my god.
I stole his berry.
Sad.
Yummy.
Yum yum yum yum.
Sidewave has never failed me.
Oh my god.
I hate alpha red.
Of course.
It's been fun so far.
Thanks for making such a cool mod.
I'm having so much fun.
Alright.
It's okay.
What's he gonna do?
Steal my berry that I stole?
Thief.
Alright.
Nice.
I did it.
Told you guys.
Sidewave has never failed me.
Wait.
It says...
No.
I killed two.
I've lost count.
This is it.
This is what we've been waiting for.
Oh wait.
It does nothing.
Okay.
Never mind.
I still don't know my type advantages.
I still...
I thought...
Guys.
I lost.
What is Sidewave good against?
Guys.
Wait.
Is it not poison?
I guess I'll never know.
Apparently nothing.
Oh.
It's a fixed damage.
No.
It's okay.
Okay.
Minion's dead.
One of life's greatest mysteries.
It's okay.
I'll send a baby out.
I'll send a baby out to fight a man's game.
All right.
Go use Spark.
It's all right.
Surely this one guy's not gonna kill my entire party.
Go Hydrogen Baby.
Don't worry.
My coughing baby shall kill this Hydrogen Bomb.
Yay.
I'm lost in the sand.
My Toad cosplayer.
Congratulations on your win in a Battle Swap Challenge.
Please accept this prize.
Wait a minute.
There you are, Mario.
I'm not surprised you're proficient in capture battles.
But that doesn't matter now.
What does matter is in testing on my team.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Great.
Because I'm looking forward to learning a lot in this battle.
Do I get my own team back?
Or do I still have the baby?
Oh, yes.
I got my own team back.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
It's Dr. Mario.
It's the viruses.
That's where I'm gonna throw you.
Oh, my God.
It's the Dr. Mario background music.
I'm gonna pill you.
Yeah.
It's time.
It's time for your vaccine shot.
Yay.
Go, Dad.
Go.
Let's go.
Beat those virus up.
What did you learn?
You couldn't cut it.
You couldn't cut the baby?
Okay.
We don't need this trick.
Nice.
We don't need that.
It's not a fighting move.
Fighting moves only.
Alright.
Learn air cutter.
Nice.
Wait.
Sweet kiss.
Who wants to learn a kiss?
Oh, it wasn't baby Yoshi.
If it was baby Yoshi, I'd put that moveset in.
Alright.
We don't trick.
We brute force.
Oh, is there the other virus?
It's time to throw the other one.
Alright.
Get in here.
Okay.
Wait.
He's a little strong.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
I'm paralyzed.
Wait a minute.
That's okay.
If one throw doesn't work, I'll use the other throw.
Oh, he also punched.
Wait.
He's also fighting.
No.
My 10k.
Guys, I can't keep spending money on surgery.
I can't keep.
Alright.
Nice.
It's okay.
We'll fix him.
There's free healthcare down in Mario Land.
Okay.
Well, it's another virus.
You know what?
Wait.
Actually...
No.
I think...
I'm gonna make him fight one more.
It's okay.
I have Husky Goon.
Alright.
Uh...
Jodlock time.
I love the BGM in this game.
Niner.
Yeah.
You can't run away now.
Got you in.
I locked you in.
That's right.
Get out of here.
The 1.
100 times I use a different mind.
Wait.
I learned body slam.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys.
I know like...
I have two really good moves.
Swallow and spit up.
But then...
Then he can body slam.
Okay.
Guys.
I think we all agree we replace spit.
Right?
We all...
I think we all agree.
Baby Yoshi only swallows.
Exactly.
He ain't no quitter.
I did not raise a quitter.
That's successful.
It's time!
Oh my god.
I've only...
I waited for this day.
Oh my god.
He can slap.
Alright.
Tail slap.
Stretch the foe with his tail.
Okay.
That shit...
Move fucking sucks.
You're never whipping your tail.
Did not learn.
I see if there's a few bugs I gotta work out.
Everything seems to be running.
Thanks for helping me test everything, Mario.
What's that?
You need a passcode for Wario Studio?
That makes sense.
The second word is gonna.
But that's all I know.
Good luck cracking the code.
Alright.
Goodbye, Penny.
Mario found the second word to unlock WarioWare.
Gonna.
Congrats on winning the Battle Swap Challenge.
Here's your prize.
There should be a third evil, right?
You guys said I was gonna get Chungus.
This is the only reason I didn't use a stone.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm checking.
I'm making sure.
What was this?
An uncanny toy like Amaton.
And throw large rocks over it.
Okay.
When does he evolve?
What level?
Oh, okay.
Level up one at level 36.
Okay, we're almost there.
Alright.
I need to know.
Where are you?
Oops.
God, I always fuck it up.
When do you become my big boy?
This is the only reason I kept you.
I would have kept you as a baby.
Okay.
Level one up to...
Yoshi evolves from baby Yoshi.
And then to level 50.
Okay.
So, like...
The only reason why I kept him around as not baby Yoshi.
Is because I need him to level up to Chungus Yoshi.
Because Big Yoshi is, like, my favorite music song ever.
This is actually...
It lives, like...
Big Yoshi lounge lives rent free in my head for, like, the longest time.
Because it's actually, like, my favorite.
Oh, wait.
That's level...
Not...
Oh.
Oh, level up.
Okay, level up.
Okay.
This is my...
One of my favorite songs.
I'm playing it right now.
I have a giant Yoshi acrylics...
Oh, no.
Sticker.
Like...
Wait.
Let me see what I...
It's somewhere.
Giant...
Big Yoshi sticker.
I...
I have...
It's, like...
Oh, it's this.
I literally own this extra large sticker.
But I don't know if there's, like, a size comparison.
I found it.
Oh, man.
It is...
Okay.
This giant ass extra large sticker is 9.5 inches.
Wait.
Is it?
Yeah.
It's 9.5 inches.
And I don't know what to do with it.
I just bought it just because I can.
You're right.
All right.
Mr. fucking overconfidence guy there.
Oh, that's just not right.
All right.
Let's see the daycare.
Did you guys meet a baby?
It's you.
We're raising your capture.
My goodness.
Your capture had an egg.
You want it?
Yes, I do.
Of course I do.
All right.
Step aside.
We got to let a baby in here.
We got to step aside.
Congratulations.
Medi and Alan.
You guys made a child.
Yes.
I would like to have this child.
All right.
Where are you?
Oh, my God.
Look at you.
What will hatch from this?
It will take some time.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
Medi and John.
Oh, my God.
Medi, John.
Congratulations.
You have a new child.
I wonder if it's going to be a boy or a girl.
He he.
All right, Doki.
Hope you and dad is all okay.
Best wishes to see you.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah, we're okay.
We're okay.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
Let's go in.
Mario.
Boy, am I glad to see you, bro.
What are you doing here?
Oh, you're going into the haunted mansion?
You don't say.
I don't suppose you need your...
Go...
Brother?
No.
Oh, okay.
You can have it yourself.
I trust you.
I don't need...
I don't need Luigi.
You may almost bankrupt Nintendo.
Anyway, to prove that I could totally...
Go inside, bro.
If I wanted to...
Let's battle!
In front of my child?
In front of Medi and...
And John's child?
I'm going out for milk.
Medi, thank you for the super chat thing.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
They're all naked.
Oh, your Goombas are naked.
I'm going to throw them.
Oh, wait.
I never healed.
I forgot to heal.
Oops.
I knew I forgot something.
What is...
Okay, let me...
Let me heal them real quick.
Let me...
Um...
It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
Oh, wait.
All right.
Bubbles?
Who's Bubbles?
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
I should not put Bubbles out.
I should not put Dad out.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Wait.
No, we have Husky Goon.
Yeah, that's not okay.
It's okay.
Look, guys.
Type advantages.
I'm doing it.
Okay.
I have Vinewood.
What's that?
Octazooka?
Oh, yeah.
I'm doing it.
I'm using types.
Yeah.
Go, Dad.
Go.
Bulk up.
What is bulk up?
Oh, yeah.
We don't need it.
It's okay.
You're...
You don't need to...
You don't need to take those powder drinks, guys.
Except if they're...
If it's Gamersupps, though.
But Dad doesn't.
He's already bulked up.
But it's okay, guys.
If you guys want to bulk up just like Dad, you can use my code DokiBird for 10-15% off at Gamersupps.
True.
Look, Dad is already too swole.
He doesn't need more.
I forgot who Bitey...
Oh, Bitey is the plant.
Yeah.
Bitey is his piranha plant.
And I called him stupid for picking them.
Alright.
It's okay.
I have...
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Somebody put him down.
What the fuck is that?
Bro.
What did you give him?
What did you give your plant?
Alright.
Let's go.
Guys.
He definitely had...
This guy definitely had...
Definitely bulked up.
Oh, my God.
Luigi.
What did you...
What did you do to him?
He...
He used fertilizer.
He got him the good fertilizer.
He put him...
He put him with all the other Yoshis.
He grabbed the fertilizer.
Swagger.
You are not cool enough for this, Hefli.
Yeah, I know.
Alright.
No.
Who's the last one?
Wait, you...
Koopa never leveled up?
I think I got my balance back.
What's happening, bro?
Alright.
I'm throwing your turtle.
Never mind.
It's okay.
I'm paralyzed anyway.
Okay.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Leave.
Yeah.
Jeepers creepers.
Wait a second.
That's right.
Give me your 420.
Boy.
You really know how to fight, bro.
It looks like you don't need your brother in there with you.
I told you no.
Okay.
I guess I see you around, bro.
You're all so loud.
Come on.
I don't have all day.
Okay.
I need a heal.
I forgot the heal last time.
Um...
Where?
Where is the Pokemon Center?
Where is it?
Okay.
I walked in a circle.
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
I'm gonna call it here.
So I can rest my voice.
And I talked a lot.
And there were so many toads.
But I always have a great time with you guys.
It's great to be back again.
Um...
We have a long week this week.
So lots of streams this week.
Um...
But thank you guys for coming.
I hope you guys enjoyed part 2 of Super Mario Mon.
It was great to see Alpha Rat join in and watching me.
It was really a huge honor that he watched my playthrough.
So thank you for stopping by.
And thank you Dragon's 2 for watching today.
Um...
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna rest my voice now.
Because there were so many toads.
There...
There were so many toads.
Hey guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Also ending stream is a little different.
Now...
We have a new addition in the ending stream.
Bye bye everyone.
Bye.